there is a report very interesting
article which we're linking to which
claims that Donald Trump is glued to
watching the stock market and that he's
starting to panic about his role in
causing what appears to be a building
recession which is hard to believe for
me only insofar as I've seen no evidence
that Trump can actually self reflect
about how he does things poorly and
about how he might be to blame for
things that happen in the world I've not
seen any evidence that he's able to do
that but the facts are pretty obvious
right the stock market is in chaos last
week we had an 800 point drop one day
followed by a drop of around 400 points
the following day stocks now are down
for the year about three and a half to
four percent not including the fact that
as I speak right now the Dow is down
another 500 points I cry when I log into
my retirement mutual fund account it's
extraordinarily depressing and in
addition to that you have stocks down
more than ten percent from their recent
highs so down about four four and a half
percent for the year down about ten to
twelve percent from there Donald Trump
highs in addition to that we have a
disastrous jobs number we had a November
jobs report where new jobs fell short of
expectations by about 50,000 jobs that
momentum of job creation turned over to
trump by the Obama administration
continues to trail off a hundred and
fifty five thousand jobs created in
November about fifty thousand jobs short
of the expectation now I have no
interest in being deceptive about the
numbers job creation is still better
than job loss right so that's good just
remember that the economy needs to
create jobs just to account for the
growing population right so the
population grows so in order to maintain
an even unemployment rate you need to be
creating some jobs just to account for
new people who are in the workforce
because of population growth okay
there's now a report from The Wall
Street Journal not a liberal newspaper
to be sure which claims that Donald
Trump is more
more panicked behind-the-scenes he's
watching the movement of the stock
market very closely he's asking advisors
if his tariffs might be to blame for the
economic turmoil and sources are telling
the Wall Street Journal that overall
Trump is still mostly blaming the
Federal Reserve's interest rate
decisions for the shaky stock market but
that the turmoil is starting to get even
to Donald Trump and that's a sign that
things really aren't going well pat
because he doesn't exactly have a
personality type which reflects about
how he might be responsible for anything
bad that happens even thinking about the
fact that he might be responsible for
this chaos tells us a lot about what's
going on and if this gets very very bad
I'm not sure what he's going to try to
blame it all on like I don't think that
the Federal Reserve raising interest
rates is going to be a point that sticks
as to why the economy in the stock
market are doing so poorly he's gonna
have to come up with something better
than that and I think it's probably
accurate to say that in instead of Trump
is worried that he's causing the the
turmoil it might be more accurate to say
Trump is worried that other people will
blame him for causing the turmoil right
so along those lines
you could argue that this leak about
Trump quote panicking about stocks and
jobs is not Trump being worried that
he's damaging the economy but Trump
being worried that others will blame him
of that and that he doesn't actually
believe it because again there's no
evidence that I've seen that Donald
Trump is capable of the kind of
introspection and self-reflection that
this leak suggests he has even though
rational people of course realized that
Donald Trump has kind of cornered
himself by taking credit for things in
the economy during his first year that
really didn't have anything to do with
him the perception of Trump as an
economic genius is now in question among
people who actually were tricked into
believing that in the first place I'm
not one of those people Donald Trump
obviously still wants to see himself as
the economic genius but he's starting to
realize that others are going to start
questioning what what exactly is Trump
doing that's me
making jobs reports get worse and worse
what exactly is Trump doing that's
putting the stock market into a freefall
and in real terms for any president it's
a bad idea to brag about the stock
market particularly when it's the stock
market of the Obama economy that Donald
Trump inherited Trump owns the next two
years of this term and we'll see what
direction that takes and a really
important note and I want to make sure
that I'm not ignoring this when we talk
about stocks and job numbers many of the
indicators that really relate to how the
average person is doing are not
represented from stocks and jobs wages
accessibility of health care
affordability of education inflation
meaning how much things cost inequality
none of that stuff is noted in these
numbers and those are extraordinarily
important indicators so yes these
numbers stocks and jobs matter they seem
to have Trump rattled they are a part of
understanding how the economy is doing
but there is much more much more that we
need to look at to really do a holistic
assessment of how the economy is doing
send me your thoughts about this
particular question do you believe Trump
is actually capable at a sort of fitness
level a temperamental level of
considering whether his actions are
resulting in bad things or is this just
a leak to try to make Trump look more
introspective than he is the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman I look forward to
hearing from you I am thrilled to tell
you that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman Blink
astiz a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why
linguist is so amazing they take the
most important information the themes
the insights from each book and they
distill it into a 15 minute audio book
that you can listen to in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm slash Pakman that's be
Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n